hello good uh afternoon I think thanks
so much for coming uh it's exciting for
me as I've never been to positon before
so it's a really new experience for me
um my name is uh indeed hes mu Eisen um
once my clicker works then I will be
happier there we go um and I'm here to
talk about inprocess analytical uh data
management with duck DB um just a quick
whole who here has heard of duct TV oh
wow and who has not heard of duct TV
okay so um that's that's I'm really I'm
really happy about that because you know
like it's um it's good to good to see
that people have heard of us um I want
to start a bit with like a bit of
motivation why activ exists um and it
actually is interesting how that is very
deeply connected to the our
community so in the tradition of putting
Hadley on a slide um um I was working in
a database architectures research group
back in Amsterdam a couple of years ago
and then we realized that data
scientists and specifically our users um
really hate the data management systems
and it hurt a feel our feelings a little
bit so here's a quote from Hadley um if
your data fits in memory there is no
advantage of putting into a database it
will only be slower and more
frustrating okay and we have we thought
very much about that and we have then we
realized that he was right um databases
can be very frustrating so here we have
sort of the you know the good and the
bad uh Bandits here and they can be very
bad uh setting up databas is very
difficult um even for somebody who has a
a PhD in data management systems setting
up postgress is a daunting task
sometimes um this seriously and I have I
have seriously I've I've set up so many
systems over the years because you know
you need to run experiments and so on so
forth and my favorite one I think like a
little anecdote you cannot literally
install IBM db2 and Oracle on the same
machine it's just not possible but of
course you know it took me a week to
realize this anyways installation um
maintenance uh yeah so then once you
have installed this thing uh you need to
somehow make sure it runs you know we
have to deal with user accounts all that
stuff you have to update all not very
pretty and something that really came
out when we worked with data people is
the data transfer in fact we wrote a a
paper about how slow transfer back and
forth from databases you would actually
not believe that if if you not start to
run experiments in it even for something
like spark you know that uses just
ancient protocols is not a great great
use experience so that's bad there is
also good things in databases for
example you know the the I don't know 40
or so no actually at this point it's 50
years since relational databases have
existed um we have spent a lot of of
time on optimizing queries so that the
user doesn't have to actually become a
database engine in their head and start
you know reshuffling things order to
make them faster this should be
automatic persistence right the original
motivation of making data management
systems was to get rid of these file
zoos that people right like you know
custom programs to operate on to make
changes to set files and instead have
sort of a defined transactional
persistence model with updates and
consistency that's quite useful um um
and of course most notably especially in
my community of analytical data
management systems um we have spent a
lot of time working on efficiency and
parallelism but the problem was that the
frustrating bits were kind of hiding the
good stuff and the good way of looking
at this was that people have been sort
of ignoring the sandwich Principle as I
like to call it people have spent a lot
of time optimizing like the Patty
whether it's vegetarian or not is up to
you um optimizing that till the end of
the the world like there is hundreds of
papers on how to optimize a join but we'
literally vote the first paper on
optimizing client protocols right um
nobody has already looked at the user
endend user experience and I think
that's why people perceive these things
as to be frustrating and would actually
rather invent their own than to touch
that stuff so incomes D so we brote a
new data management system from scratch
um together with um my former PhD
student Mar Gra felt um that basically
try to fix this endtoend user experience
so it's um it's in process I will
explain to you in a bit what that means
just so that you can have a better user
experience um it is still despite
focusing on the endtoend a
state-of-the-art uh data execution
engine that can you know really um go
through data in a very very quick way um
and the best part it's free and open
source so you can just use it it's MIT
licensed I always say you know go build
a company on it I'm going to be happy
about it first question why is it called
duct Deb it's because I used to have a
duck
okay it's true what can I say
um okay so let me go a bit about the
sort of the design philosophy of dub the
first is it should be simple right like
we shouldn't have to have ahd in
databases in order to set this thing up
and we also it also shouldn't be you
know like hard to use so one thing we
noticed is that a database that a lot of
people are quite quite comfortable with
is sqlite and why is sqlite so easy to
use well because it's in process which
means that the data database system
actually runs directly to whichever
process you link to so in R you have k r
sqlite package that you can just like
load and then you can just run sqlite
without any external setup isn't that
great so we copy that idea for dub dub
runs fully in process uh which also has
some really great benefits for data
transfer um one of the other
frustrations that I will talk to you uh
in a bit
about dctb doesn't have
dependencies um so we just have a giant
blob of C++ code that uh well yeah that
you can just install with install
packages right it's it doesn't have
external dependencies besides DBI and R
um in in in Python it works uh I said
the p word it works the same way you can
just you can just install uh dub as a
package and it will just and then it
will just
run but again you don't you shouldn't be
fooled by it being simple uh by taking
it as simplistic or sort of you know
Limited in terms of what the engine can
do so as I mentioned we have
transactions we have persistence we have
extensive relational features like you
know complex joints Aggregates window
functions duct TB can read and write
parket files out of the box c v files
Json file all in parallel it's really
quite fully featured
um dctb is very fast too and you know I
know everybody says this but this is not
just like oh we run a benchmark and was
fast but the people always ask me why is
it fast what do you do and then it's
sometimes very difficult to explain so I
asked um the team what I should say and
I said just say It's
Magic of course any sufficiently
advanced uh technology is
indistinguishable from Magic as you know
so what is the magic here magic is that
it's the culmination of Decades of
research in analytical data management
systems literally tens of phds went into
the basic concepts that we that we
basically implemented in DP some of in
our own group in the database research
group in Amsterdam some from other
groups but it really is this culmination
how does this sort of show itself well
um one of the advantages of dub and that
makes it really fast is that it can
automatically paralyze very complex SQL
query queries over all the available SQL
CPU cores but the the problem is that
this Al Spar can also do this but the
problem is in order to get good
utilization it's not enough to just
blindly paralyze you also have to get a
good efficiency on a per core level and
de is also really good at that um with
tight highly efficient C++ code um for
example can also use the disk if there's
not enough RAM available to complete a
query so we can go out of core on all
the operators and this all happens
completely um sort of automatically
transparently to the user so you just
type your query and go off one thing
that you can sort of notice when you're
run duct that your laptop might get a
bit warm right that's just that's a bit
of a downside sometimes if it's hot
outside I
know um yeah and I mentioned drb is free
so it's just you know no no choose all
four um a bit about R uh since everybody
here Loves R drb Loves R as well in fact
the whole idea of creating a new
database management system came out of
the interactions with the r community
and I want to mention Thomas Lumley and
Anthony damiko maybe some of you know
them um who really pushed us because we
were working with them as a sort of why
do you hate us so much and then you know
we came up with Solutions and they said
yeah this better but still not good
enough and we we know we went back to
our little uh you know lab and continued
and continued um and this was really
productive it went on from many years
and in the end it was really clear what
needed to happen and also how to deeply
integrate that into R we also worked a
lot with with our core on for example
the entire altre framework so we could
do more clever things with with dub in
connections with r so one thing that's
really clever uh that came out of this
is that DB runs in process in R it runs
in the same
process uh as like the r interpreter
itself okay that that sounds a bit
technical I realized that but one big
advantage of that is that if because we
running the same process we can actually
look at the data frames that exist in
the r process itself so if you want to
just run a query on a data frame we
don't have to sort of go through like
some serialization write it to park file
read it again I don't know uh we can
just look directly at the
memory um and say hey this looks like
some bits from a data frame maybe you
can just make that look like a table and
then you can run query on it and
similarly the query results in dctb can
directly become our data frames in the
same process without having to go
through IPC or anything like that right
so we can basically say you run a query
it has a has a million rows result sets
which normally would be the end of the
world in uh sort of traditional setup
with client server um but with Dube
that's just like okay there you go um we
even have some sort of Tricks where we
sometimes we don't even have to
transform the data we can directly use
the r structure
again saying the p word of course the
same trick also works in pandas so if
you have a pandas data frame sitting
there um that works as well um but now
I'm going to sort of do the uh
unimaginable and try a live
demo um wish me
luck what how am I on
time eight minutes that's perfect um so
so for our people in the back I'm going
to switch to to to mirroring here
because otherwise I cannot see what on
Earth is going on
on
okay oops can you read this in the back
uh can you read in the back okay so
R so I'm just going to I'm just going to
copy paste some code because nobody
wants to see me typing while I'm a bit
nervous um what no not install packages
see I already made a mistake I don't
want to install packages because the
Wi-Fi is wonky so in order to start up
duct DB um you you just basically you
load up DBI okay and then you can do a
DB connect like the really traditional
DBI thing that's um thing and for this
demo I have two connections I have a
concore PG and have a concore DD the pg1
obviously talks to a a pocra server that
I have just here running locally on my
laptop as a comparison point for the
some of the things I've been talking
about um and let let's generate some
data uh so I'm going to I'm going to
generate some data here so this is
just um data oh yeah it's a wonderful
name I know um this is just a three
column double data set nothing really
too dramatic of course DB works with
arbitrary you know data frames it's just
for the demo um and this uh data frame
has 10 million rows like not crazy um
but of course that's carefully chosen so
some of my comparisons will actually
finish in the time I have left in this
talk okay so so now I'm going to just
import that into
postgress and I might maybe take some
questions in the
meantime
yeah so the client server protocol
really kills you there because all the
data well all the 10 million rows have
to now go through a socket even though
it's on the same machine and yeah okay
here we go 10 seconds uh so that that is
that is something that that will will
just take a long time to go to the to
the external database server and if I do
the same thing induct DB I would not be
able to take questions because as it is
in process it will just it will just
directly go to the to the the engine
running in r one thing I should mention
here this is not an IM memory kind of
game so duct TB is running in an on disk
mode which means that we have actually
written this data to the disk flushed
called Fung the whole you know the whole
thing like the transactionality
everything happened the same sort of
thing that you would expect from a
database server okay now we can try the
same thing in Reverse we'll just call DB
R table on the thing we've just
written oh yeah 5 Seconds okay so that's
that's now the inverse we've tried to we
have to go through the same sort of
socket problem again now let's do the
same induct Deb again and now this is
where this really shines because we have
created this entire data set from the
table data that was stored on disk back
into an R data frame in like 0.1 seconds
that's I'm happy about that and why this
is kind of funny is I have this like
really basic model fitting and please
don't laugh at my uh you know linear
model code here because I have no idea
what I'm doing um but I think like
transferring the data out of postris
takes 5 Seconds fitting thank you a
linear model to it takes 1.6 seconds you
would say that one is a bit more
difficult than the other right one is
just like copy the other is like okay we
have to do the damn thing with the
residuals and so on so this is just a I
think 0.1 second St is the right sort of
relationship to that to that number okay
um but I mentioned that we can directly
look at data frames that are in the r
memory space so here let me show you
something that is not in DBI um maybe I
should you know arm wrestle K to add it
um in we can just basically say in dctb
we can say dub register and what that
and give it a connection and a table
name in this came in this case it's the
wonderful Mt cars um and then give it a
data frame and say look I want you to to
treat this data frame as a table but no
actual copying is going on right we're
not we're not we're not doing the import
we're not doing anything we just say
look duct DB here's a pointer to a data
frame please try to treat it as a table
and then once we have done that we can
just run a query so I can say hey select
star from Mt cars blah blah blah and it
will just you know low and behold run
this query for you or I can can also
like do some bit more complicated things
so here I'm running a a distinct I'm
sorry on um on a on a particular column
and in cars and I'm doing a filter here
with the wear column and I'm asking dctb
to show me what the query plan is going
to be remember I told you about the
whole you now automatic end to end
optimization so we have these like
operators that we string together the
highly efficient operators like a group
buyer filter and down here we have the
data frame scan which is the thing that
basically just looks at the data frame
and runs uh and and it treats as a
table and this can also done this can
also this also works with a bit more
complicated use example so here I'm
taking some taxi data this uh table is a
bit bigger is 2.5 gab of park it has uh
eight uh it has a lot of rows let me
actually actually you know I why don't
to just uh find out how many rows there
are
here uh now you get to do it after all
from
see okay so this
is 84 million rows that's a bit more
sizable and now I can basically take a
very heavy query here that
computes the um the day and hour and the
tip amount as a median Group by day and
hour of the stat it's a fairly complex
query it will be one of these queries
that will actually make your um you know
your computer warmer and even that quite
heavy
um uh hang on I want to do the um query
completes in a very very short time okay
so now I'm going back to my slides that
concludes the demo it went well I think
um to to conclude uh so dctb I was
talking dctb dctb is an inprocess
analytical data management system I try
to explain what that means uh it's very
simple it's feature Rich fast free and
you just choose all four um and it is
really deeply integrated with R in fact
uh I'm quite happy on how now our core
has been responsive to our requests of
changing things in R itself so we can
make data base integration into R
quicker it's kind of an I don't think
that happens with Oracle let's just say
um and now I'm really happy to take some
questions thank you so I have a quick
question before the next speaker um
you've showed an example of Dr be
processing a data frame very very
quickly um Can U other structures such
as nested list data be used in the same
way um that's a great question so we
actually we're working on doing nested
structures in data frames um we also
support scanning Arrow objects in R um
but like raw lists uh I think you have
to add a class data frame to them before
you can scan them okay okay thank you
let's thank our speaker once
again